[Music]
welcome to this week's winners on a
Wednesday I'm extremely excited to have
on the show Pierce because he literally
came to the crash course and within two
weeks he had his first deal on his
making money from it is now making three
thousand pounds a month income from
property so Pierce welcome to the show
thank you so thanks for me you're so
welcome man thanks for coming down so
why don't you just tell us a little bit
about what happened because I know you
started watching my youtube videos yeah
you then got a lead yeah and then you
were thinking I need to make sure I've
got the right knowledge now came to the
crash course got the right knowledge and
then bang a cure debts I want to talk
about how I got into you know your
videos so obviously as you know I've got
a small high street stay agent yeah and
I had to climb that come in who is
looking to buy a property in hole now
generally my client's are always buying
property around the surrounding area
because their first aren't buyers they
don't know nothing about the areas and
this gentleman actually said I want to
buy an hole and I'm like how why are you
buying in hole because I generally help
them bite do the the whole buying
process yeah so help them with life so
now their mortgages part of negotiation
and completing with the solicitors and
stuff like that so it's kind of hot
hand-holding service so this gentleman
said I went to a crash course with this
guy called Sammy when at that time I
didn't know who he where so he kind of
gave me that Facebook page and he said
this is where I went and that's why they
were interested in how you know that's
where it started I thought okay cool
interesting obviously I was helping them
buy that property and throughout that
time I I was looking at investing myself
and I was looking at what what are my
opportunities so I went home and spoke
to my brother and I said oh no client
you know my client actually said this
gentleman do you know him and he was the
one who said I've seen Sandler's video
so my brother was the one then said can
you have a look as well so that's when I
started looking at video in July this
the 2018 nice one so July last year
started watching the video yeah small
world then so you brother's been
watching the videos yeah your clients
have been watching the videos and you
thought I need to I need to see what I
need to see I need to see but one thing
I was always surprising
journey was you're actually making
difference for all this stage and in the
UK because if you didn't say about how
they would have never gone on invested
in hope yeah
so that's such a positive impact to
businesses as well
yeah and that was surprised and for me
that was like who is this guys actually
making people buy all over the UK now
yeah that's interesting to know because
my client would if I say them to go and
buy in there at the location the block
no no no I'll con do that I don't know
the area I want to buy where I live so
that was interesting to see somebody not
buying a property nearly five hours away
that's probably because we've been in
crash course now I understand why
they've done it yes they've learnt in
the crash course how to get the Power
Team ready and stuff like that yeah
because they think is if you say I'm
only gonna bind their me in case there's
a problem and I need to be able to step
in yeah that's a really bad plan a yeah
I mean
that's not financial freedom that's a
rope around your neck that's I can never
go on holiday because I have to I'll
have to be there if there's a problem so
the real key is is to find good people
like yourself you're an estate agent
find good people that can do the
management side of it but ya know you do
and and instead of the ROI systems in
place absolutely and then that was it so
that I started looking at watching your
videos all the crash course videos as
well and I thought I told my brother one
day I said I booked it and it's free
yeah so that was it like we've booked
there we're going in so September end of
September when it was the crash cause
dates came out so it was a few months
ago now there yeah but saving might be
four months ago end of September so yeah
only four months ago so we've booked in
and it was so when we put the crash
cause we didn't know my sister was
traveling and my little nephew who
doesn't live in the country they come in
every two years to see us so it happened
to be back that weekend
they were flying back so that Sunday
they were flying back yeah so why do I
had to do was world with me and blah
blah blah
we're like we want to spend time with
family ball so we want to go into crash
course so we just went to the crash
course and those two days was phenomenal
yeah I learned a lot and my brother as
well it has always been one of those
person being in the back you know he
would always support me and doing things
and he's actually came alongside me
together and actually learned like
days words phenomenal amazing us so good
tell us about this deal then that you
secured we how long after the crash
course was 10 days 10 days so 10 days
after the crash course yeah you actually
secured a deal yeah and tell us the
figures on that deal well at the moment
that that's four so four apartments in
total so you secured look so it was it
was one agent or was it with a done
landed direct story alright landlord so
it was one direct landlord yeah but he
had four apartments in a block means in
a block yeah how much money are those
four apartments now making you I would
say about three thousand pounds so
you're making three thousand eyes from
from just that one from that one
landlord yeah that block yes so on
average about four thousand and it was
the money all three pass sorry three
thousand yeah and is the money all
coming in now is it all set up
yes is yeah so it's a credible so I was
the deal then how does it work so he was
he was a landlord who was trying to sell
his block first of all actually
well I'll good if four blocker for pot I
mean with a different staging yeah had
no luck came to me and said appears can
you let them out now at that time before
that I didn't know how to you know you
could take time because letting is you
know somebody's got to give notice come
come and actually take over so it could
take time and I after the crash cause as
we learned our to si yeah under session
you had yeah we just went we could do it
yeah and that was it we I called him
back and said after the crash was on
Monday I called him and said can I can I
meet meet yourself and he would yeah and
that was it I was ten days later we sign
off the contract that's so brilliant and
you know what as well I don't know if
there's any estate agents or letting a
just are gonna watch this but I mean so
many people who are well so well
positioned in property yeah there might
be mortgage brokers or estate agents
letting agents whatever builders yeah
but they missing out I'm so much money
they giving you away
yeah then they're they're just the
middle people that are just passing the
deals to everyone that they're the
builders are building on the properties
to make the developers rich yeah you
know everyone's it's just crazy so I
love it I mean even when I did
my challenge you know the FF challenge
yeah correct did you enjoy that by the
way it was love no it's going crazy that
visually when you pick the Sheffield yo
and DfE at that time yeah we were my
heart was pumping and I was like yeah
but we knew you were going to do it yeah
we just knew it I know but um but the
the some of the deals that I found on
that on that while in that week the
estate agents who didn't know who I was
have watched the documentary and then
now doing deals themselves like like
what you've done for an it because
they're thinking well I'm in a really
good position here so it's really cool
having you having you as an estate agent
as a property person on the show because
you know some people want watches and
said oh he was already in a state agent
so it's easy for him but you can always
find you've just got to take the cards
that you're dealt with yeah and then
just and then just one of those I
remember you saying sometimes you know
that session we had in crash course yeah
about 20 pound oh yeah when you're
getting that opportunity sometimes we
don't see as an opportunity and we let
it go yeah and it sometimes is all about
the mindset yeah and and those two days
in crash course was we just sat down and
went here you go this is what we could
have done months ago and we could you
know but just getting that knowledge
about those two days and come in and
actually doing it with you right and
then those three sorry four properties
that you've got yeah just to be really
clear for anyone that isn't familiar of
rent to rent yeah so you're giving the
landlord a guaranteed ranch yes and then
your real etting it out yeah and then
you're keeping the profit so you don't
own it but you're doing this with the
correct paperwork Bret contracts its
aboveboard is legal yeah and you're
making three grand a month
some months you might be more some of us
might be little bit less but on average
during the four months three grand a
month and and that's how much - how much
time you have to spend on on that
because we manage it ourselves
I do I do spend I'd say about a day in
total of the week do all the paperwork
and judgment and stuff like that yeah
just because it's quite close to me I'd
do that yeah but if I had to now do it
somewhere else and actually systemize it
yeah it would be quite easy - sure so as
well okay but the thing is 3,000 pound a
month yeah for one day a week yeah it's
pretty good yeah yeah a good how we
doing before back right now
what what I want to talk about is
actually I don't know if you remember
when in our Advanced Course yeah oh the
very first month I was actually when I
when I've got the r2s that I still
didn't have enough knowledge yeah and
when we had our advanced training yeah
when I sat down and I said Samuel I
forgot that I had an opportunity to show
you my figures and you said piers you're
not making enough money and one of your
quarterly goal was to actually revisit
your essays yeah
guess what I wasn't doing I didn't have
a channel manager at place okay you were
the one said go and get this channel
manager yeah get sorted and since they
you were doing the work yourself too
much and you didn't have the right team
and infrastructure correct yeah so now
after getting the power team in place
yeah it's much more easier using you
like trying to manager now yeah
straightaway we're getting a lot more
presence online good actually that
channel manager has put us top and
Google as well Phantom that's when we
started getting real fantastic and
presumably you're doing a lot less now
as well we are doing a lot less yeah
yeah I think his knowledge is really
important but so's Network yeah people
think the most important thing is having
a lot of money actually no no the most
important thing you having a lot of
knowledge and having a good Network and
then the money will just follow so
that's that's awesome
okay so tell us some of the key learning
points then that you've cuz I hate even
this weekend how did it feel sorry I had
to ask how did he feel being on stage in
front of a thousand people it was
amazing
yeah absolutely amazing I was out
actually about to go home do you
remember yeah and you went pins you're
not gonna know and you're meant to go on
stage yeah yeah and it was amazing
because you were you were red-eyed all
those words
I was tired we started our day really
early it was amazing event
yeah thousands of people like helping
each other yeah I was thank you so much
for having me as offer you have to point
out so it was about quite late I was a
little bit tired I was about to leave
home I had an hour journey and your life
is you've got to go and stay yeah I just
thought you'd been that you'd been there
you'd help so you'd help so where you're
running around with microphones thousand
people I thought I'm not then we go
stage I'm gonna get on stage yeah I'm
gonna honor him and you can say a few
words
yeah so so I love pushing people out
there convers own and you smashed it bro
thank you so much so so what's been the
big learning points then in the last
chemo
doing being on the training well for me
it has been been been doing the advanced
horse yeah has showed me a lot of
different opportunities just though the
record anyone who's watching this isn't
sure so you did the crash course yeah
the crash course enabled you to go and
get your first few deals yeah which is
bringing you three grand a month in
absolutely brilliant yeah but because it
was it went so wow you were thinking if
you put a pound in a slot machine and
two pound comes out yeah you're gonna
put another pound in right correct so so
you gave your time came to the crash
course but now you're on the academy
yeah this is a 12-month program where
you get to chat with me that's very into
my against my life lifestyle at the
moment has turned into being in Samuel
Leeds group on Facebook group yeah you
know seeing things all the time ball so
my biggest takeaways been I've been I've
been in business for nearly five years
they're not even spending time with
family has been my massive problem yeah
you know I've never had a chance to do
it now I've got so much time to actually
give my family as well which is amazing
but the biggest learning for me has been
I do courses every pretty much I'd say
me enough every month in the Academy we
do different rental rent course we did
power property power explosion so this
courses have put me a lot of tools that
I never knew around investment yeah
I've always been helping first-time
buyers and not being able to get into an
investor market so not only you've
helped me to understand investment but
you also have helped me to understand
what an investor marquees yes oh he's
helped me both way so now I've got you
know I've now got a new deal dice I said
you with the sa management yes so so the
story behind is it's amazing because
this landlord actually started an essay
he refurbed his six bedroom
started himself couldn't do it called me
and said do you want to come in so it's
pretty much a no money down deal for me
so I haven't put anything he's done
everything he's got the essay ready i've
systemized my business before for SI now
i can go there and literally do i'm
doing it as we speak
the thing is what you've done piers is
you've turned from a state agent yep to
a property entrepreneur and the investor
that's happened right so before you were
just you you had
a job basically was it your business
who's your business but it was a job but
now you're an entrepreneur yeah which is
fantastic yeah I don't know you how old
are you 27 same age as me man yep same
age as me some people are gonna watch
that and they're gonna feel you know
like bad because of that like all these
guys above 27 and and I've not achieved
that much you know just I would already
courage just be inspired yeah you know
just be inspired because also sometime I
know it's some people they're quite old
and they've got themselves off I uh I'm
60 I'm too old well hold on if you're 60
you've still got a good 10 years left of
working life like you can achieve as
much it between 60 and 70 as I can
between 25 and 35 and what you might
like in in in energy you make up in
experience of course so and that's
that's what we've learned from your
financial freedom challenge yeah is to
to take that knowledge yeah go anywhere
and you can still deliver that yeah
and I've seen that happening within
myself and my brother yeah who's in the
Academy as well yeah and we're both you
know giving each other so much feedback
on how we can do yeah how we can do this
how we can approach their agents and it
has been amazing for us with this
education and tell us about your
background because I leave at a tough
background like you had a franchise that
didn't really work of money worked a lot
of hours yet loads of flowers I did
seven days a week
there's a retail franchise yeah I didn't
work for me at all did it for two nearly
two and a half years yeah then I had to
shut it down which was a bit shame yeah
but you could have given up at that
point you could have said you don't
forget it I'm just gonna get a job and
I'm not gonna try and be entrepreneurial
anymore but you didn't you carried on I
carried on and I think that's that's
really that's that's the key to success
sometimes just carrying on Easy's and
sometimes this before it was just my
background is I did my levels of
completed but I never went to university
yeah so I've never invested in myself
that has never been the case all right I
am quite good going online and doing it
myself
yeah but and actually not investing in
myself yeah so
2018 after I joined Kadim II i-i've seen
the change in myself
yeah I've invested time effort learning
property from yourself I
and that has completely changed how I
think yeah how I do thinks but also it
feels so good to know what you're doing
in the right way by having the right
knowledge yeah it is good I mean I
continually invest in myself people
think that when you finish school that's
it you don't need to invest in yourself
anymore and they'll happily spend 40
thousand pounds going to university
investing in formal education yep
but Jim Rohn says formal education makes
you a living but self education makes
you a fortune which is what you're kind
of doing now and tell us about some of
the people that you've met on the
academy because I know you come to the
dinners and everything don't ya yeah so
we've said though probably more
highlights at the moment is coming to
dinner yeah which you treated us was
lovely beautiful luxury place with all
this amazing people around around the
table have you know sharing experience
and stuff there's amazing numbers of
like-minded people yeah like you know
Ben is doing amazing been fairly Jen
yeah yeah I'm trying to grab him um
winners on a Wednesday he'll Gilligan is
yeah so like Ben and there's few other
people that I know made it was a really
good looking just all down the table
yeah a lot of every 40 people there for
to be prevent and nearly all of them
were like financially free everyone
pretty much in there so like what
everyone's doing amazing deal on what's
on the table and what's gonna happen
next yeah them as well yeah it's a home
I love and people say to me why do you
train well because of this I love having
it making it alone is boring yeah so yes
I've run a training business and yes
it's my mission but I also just really
love it I love making it alone is boring
yeah but I haven't changed in life since
he has it because what I've learned from
you what did I come to that crash course
just gone was is to go and give to
people what I know yeah
you know and he was so good to where I
was in September in that chairs yeah
looking at you going what do I do next
who now actually standing there in the
back and giving support to this people
yeah
really want to make it it was amazing so
what was she what advice would you give
to someone that was looking to do some
rent event deals
yeah but didn't really maybe they had
some training but then understand rent
to rent but what kind of what are the
best advice you could give to us well
besides getting trained of course yeah
but what advice would you give to
someone who was
wanting to go out and do that there very
little money and then when I start
making good cash flow like I think
education is important so that that's
something is important but you've got to
really know before you actually go and
do it you do need to know exactly the
right legal side of it yeah bol so you
know you can have amazing lot of leads
coming through because in your crash
course we learn how to get leads yeah
and a lot of people will go away to you
to know how to get leads but turning
them into deals it could be hard yeah
how do you turn a lead into a deal
there's a lot of step I've got a seven
steps process where I'll go through okay
I share maybe a couple now yeah so you
obviously you look online you get the
lead yeah once you get the leads you've
got obviously position yourself
yeah and investigate that area if you
want to invest yeah once you've done
that you actually pick up the phone yes
that's people forget to do that alright
the biggest part yeah ping up the phone
and being open and honest that's
probably where love that's that and you
know what I see people even even on the
even at the crash course when they have
to go to make calls and they're like
shaking aren't they so scared
yeah but the best things in life are
always on the other side of fear course
so let's up the phone and tell him
exactly what you do honest honest and
open up in the future if you're if it's
your first deal say it's your first deal
yeah I think it's an advantage because
you could say you know what this is
actually my first deal so that's why I'm
in it I'm gonna give you such a good
offer yeah absolutely and you know I
mean I'm gonna give you the reason the
offer is so good is because it's my
first deal and I want you to be so happy
so that you can then give me a
testimonial lately all right you flip
the cards take the cards that you've
been dealt with and use that for your
advance I've learned that for me to
actually use your landlord to be your
seller yeah now my landlords are happy
to go piers do you know what let me just
give you some reference yeah and I can
speak some more now leads are turned
into tail for boys just calling into
agents and saying look would you mind
just giving my landlord reference he
will tell you everything about what I've
been given - absolutely
that's an amazing part that powerful so
yeah so you exactly you've got a
landlord
yeah who's happy and then when you
trying to get another landlord if
they're like I'm not sure you just say
listen why don't you speak to this guy
yeah
and he's now your reference yeah he's my
reference in these cells it for me so
yeah I don't have to do anything so
that's probably what's the next step
because this is brilliant okay so be
able to show you so you Rick so you find
the deal you do the check yeah you then
pick up the phone yet you're totally
honest and upfront yeah then what so you
go and view the property obviously yeah
once you view the property obviously you
give them the right information that's
required
what kind of which is illegal legal yeah
yeah what are we girls so is the lease
allowing you to do service apartment and
the mortgage yeah you've got to check
those two absolutely
my ideal has two of my deals fall
through because of those yeah yeah yeah
I'd rather the deal a lot of people we
call the motivated idiots that go out
and secure deals but the deals aren't
necessarily good or legal yeah and all
that happens is it comes back to bite
you in the bum yeah because it's gonna
either lose your money or it's going to
damage your reputation of course I'd
rather a deal fall for it upfront yeah
because the landlord when he I'd rather
be totally honest and then I don't want
to do it yeah yeah and then say okay
well for lost and I got two minutes of
my time yeah or I check the lease it's
no good okay I've lost the bail course
then just do it anyway and then find out
that the lease is no good although
although the mortgage company doesn't
permit it or something like that so it
doesn't help other people who want to do
it properly so I've had an instant when
a stage and has said I don't want to
deal with any service department company
because I've had bad experience it's
such you know and that's one of the one
of the things that I for me being an
influencer in the property world and a
trainer it's a fine line because I want
to inspire people on my youtube channel
to go out and do it I'm like go and do
it go and do it because the learning
isn't doing at the same time when you
have stories like that like what did the
agent say they just said they had bad
experience with a motivate Libya yeah so
somebody who's done service partnering
with them before and do not want to do
and bear the agent I looked online on
Rightmove
and they've got the most lot of stop and
the best stop now they don't want to
deal with any said it's such a shame
yeah but the thing is you who've been
trained properly yet and are doing it
properly they're using the right systems
are actually helping me yeah because
you're going to be successful and then
the agent will be like oh I dealt with
an investor when I doubt was Troy
brilliant but then when I phone then
they're like I've done this before is
easy
you'll pave the way yeah so my success
students are making my life easier yeah
by paving the way helping the economy
yeah
but the people that do not do us any
favors
yeah are the people that go out and do
it wrong yeah what what you say what you
think is more dangerous because I don't
know someone that takes massive action
with no knowledge yeah or someone that
gets lots of knowledge but will never
take the action I would now I wouldn't
be able to tell that however myself
honestly because it is but you've got
going back to having that knowledge but
also implementing that yeah yeah that's
probably the biggest word I've learnt
from you yeah and I've done it dazing a
nomination implementation you've yeah
you've taught me I want to inspire
people but I also want to train people
so they can implement yeah I just want
to inspire people so as a whole bunch of
people with fire in their bellies yeah
but not no one not knowing what to do
yeah but at the same time I can tell
them what to do I could give them all
the information yeah but if they've not
got the fire in their belly then they'll
so it's this constant drawing of a boat
with key words which is being inspired
and taking action
yeah and then having the knowledge of
the training which is just so important
it's a balance of both and yeah which
we've learned from you is to do together
yeah and everything you learn in put in
place and learn put in place and it
shows that results will come of course
yeah the steps of course they'll come
yeah like no I don't know a single
person just on the academy that's doing
my advanced training who is taking
action and attending the programs yet
and failing not one so I mean some
people obviously don't take the action
but most joke yeah but okay so you then
do the legals technics okay and then
what now one thing I've been I've been
very good with is you know obviously
sending the contract and signing it
closing it very quickly yes but you
don't want to give too much time to
close a contract yeah so obviously I'll
send the contract meet the landlord
Shrek way get it signed off do you do
you have a reason to put a short because
do you create any urgency or anything
like some of one of the things I say
about lifting yet you say is also
something like look I've got I've got
quite a few other properties to see so
I'll get you the context answer both
about how soon
they're the magic words how soon would
you be able to read it over and get it
back to mate you know
did you do anything Sam I do because
because the fact that I know I want to
move on quickly with that deal yeah
although I've got loads of leads gone
through the other end I'll always let
landlord say would it be okay if I send
you the contract please have a read if
you've got any question I'm free
tomorrow morning we'll have a little
chat yes brilliant brilliant good rather
than just saying there's the contract
read it and get back to me in your own
time because then you want to strike
what the on top yeah and close the deal
nothing wrong with closing the deal
sometimes people need you need to make
it very easy for them yeah to do the
deal but also give them the support and
say look on three tomorrow morning just
give me a call yeah that way then if
they don't give you a call we've we can
give them a call and say ah I'm guessing
everything's fine have you signed the
contract yeah and that's the easiest
part yeah that is really the easiest
part but then once you've done these
types of deals like you you've met you
lots of people yourself on the on the
training and you've done it yourself I
think that it's not that difficult to
make very good money when you know what
you're doing it's a lot like you say one
day a week three grand a month and you
just go inside yeah I mean yes it's hard
in one sense yeah or it's there are
steps you need to learn yeah once you
know the steps it's very very easy as
Barry I mean I'm a very simple guy I'm
not a super intelligent person I'm not
but I'm not I'm not very academic
you didn't go to university we're just
normal people smashing out the park
I'm just 1012 years ahead of you but I'm
sure you'll overtake me one day
what were your final kind of words of
advice to people watching this that are
wanting to get into property well first
of all I would say look crash course is
where you where it all starts everyone
says that and it's almost like I tell
them to say I know it is because for me
it's happened yeah whereas if it was
July come I never knew who you were yeah
you know my my clients bought property
because you've inspired them to now took
food for you to you know do this crash
course in thousands and the energy level
10 you call it yeah I use that word a
lot nowadays the a level-10 deliver that
to people it's important that you know
exactly what you're doing yeah you know
this free stuff online your YouTube
channel has got so much content free for
people to learn yeah but it could only
take you to a certain level
yeah because without it's like it's like
the theory - a driving test yeah you do
the theory yeah you watch the videos you
do either do a books and then you go to
the practical absent we do the crash
course is the practice is a practical
when we actually spend a lot of time
finding deals and the crash calls people
find deals yeah so education part has
been the biggest thing for me like I
said I've never invested in myself and
this is the only time I've done it and
it's paying off really quickly I love
them you inspire me as an entrepreneur
when I've said you many times but the
fact that it's not only impacting my
property journey balls impact in my
entrepreneur journey which has known
exactly what to do in business and what
not to do in business so thank you so
much for in Spain you're so welcome it's
such a pleasure to work with you and I
look forward to continue towards your
success thank you yes thanks thank you
thank you so much for watching the video
that is the reason why I'm doing this
your success is my oxygen every single
week we've got people becoming
financially free if you'd like to see
more success students you can do that
right here but what I'd really suggest
is why don't you come and join us at the
property investors crash course come on
on my guest completely free and I'll
personally be there for two days to help
you get started you can see what happens
right here what you'll notice is all of
these stories they all start at the
crash course so come along my guests
can't wait to see you there peace out